nfts the new buzzword in technology
making mega bucks for some i'm going to
disney world this artist sold for more
than 50 million pounds
but what is a non-fungible token and why
are people going wild for them what we
need is an illustration
and usefully we've got one
artist emma linum's gone from paper to
tablet and now she's experimenting with
nfts how do you turn that into an nft
so
sort of it's in a two-step process so
the first step is kind of like uploading
it so we call that minting
once you've put this work onto the
internet and it's available what's the
second stage of the process you want to
get some buyers at that stage right
that's right so that's where you list it
right yep and listing involves what you
have to decide so listing is where you
decide a the price
be the quantity and then see your
creator royalties i see so each time the
things get sold
you get some wilties back from it that's
right so every time it gets sold you get
some royalties back from it and you as
an artist determine what that amount is
and that's different isn't it to the
physical works because with these you
sell them once and then that's kind of
it with this every time you get souls
you get walters that's absolutely right
yep i can see the appeal yeah
[Laughter]
good for artists like her but there's a
dark side to this digital bandwagon
today the uk's tax authority said it had
seized several nfts as part of an
investigation into vat ford worth 1.4
million pounds
these nfts are stored online inside big
noisy computer server rooms a bit like
this one they're not in the traditional
financial system and that makes them a
big potential target for money
launderers if for example you have to
send illicit funds to your criminal
associate or you want to pay
for for drugs or another kind of illicit
good what you can do is facilitate that
transaction through nfts so you might
send a sort of worthless nft uh from one
criminal to the other and then that
criminal can pay you back uh with
however much you are owed for the
illicit drugs or or whatever it might be
such crimes a small part of the nft
world but it's growing and all the
flashy animations in the world can't
airbrush that out the chatroom's blowing
up
jeff white sky news